hey guys this is dennis the founder of
think hero and this is our review of the
movie world war z starring brad pitt and
next to me is someone new to think hero
uh Vince Foster who's actually going to
be popping up in videos from time to
time but he's actually here to be more
when we start doing our sketch and
narratives web series and stuff like
that because Vince is an actor so how's
it going yeah good good thanks for
having me and happy be here yeah i watch
world war z yeah we both just watched it
together um uh what do you think overall
I thought it was a good movie okay i
liked it i enjoyed it you know i think a
lot of people had made mention of it in
comparison to other zombie flicks so i
tried to like flush all that out and
just watch it you know with with a clean
template clean slate it was good and he
was a fun ride i thought okay yeah i
thought i thought it was alright i
thought it was above average it was
definitely is not like it felt more the
two first two-thirds of the movie really
felt like a disaster movie to me
something like twenty twelve roland
emmerich's 2012 versus actual zombie
movie but then kind of the last third
turned into more of the the suspenseful
thriller type of zone yeah yeah that
you're right that is how i rolled that's
like that yeah it was like to have two
different movies but two different
you're watching two different kinds of I
don't know kinds of action yeah yeah cuz
in the beginning part it's just like all
these crazy zombies coming at you and
trying to kill people and you see
thousands and thousands of zombies yeah
and that's kind of why I thought like at
the end they were gonna have like a big
huge climactic scene of just like tons
of zombies and tons of machine guns and
soldiers and whatnot but that's actually
not what happened it kind of turned more
into a more intimate like thriller type
of kind of typical zombie or or you had
mentioned before something like Jurassic
Park with the velociraptors ya know yeah
the noises they got the noises of
stocking yeah you know trying to get
away from them and hiding and stuff like
that yeah yeah I did it it had a nice
feel to it from
Jurassic Park it was good it's just much
more suspenseful yeah well yeah yeah
drew a well they weren't relying on
those masses of zombie so they had to go
back to ya like being hunted so what do
you think of the acting in it I thought
it was good you know I it's to me it's
it's a this type of film is very
technical like the acting is very
technical because the amount of editing
and the amount you know the sheer number
of shots it's like you just have to be
able to run yell scream punch kick you
know dive it's it's not a dramatic right
right yeah it's it's a you just you know
marking it off the the checklist uh-huh
yeah yeah I thought everyone was pretty
good obviously Brad Pitt is the main
star he's kind of the main guy you see
throughout and I always forget her name
her name is a Muriel and notice i don't
know if i'm pronouncing that right she's
she's a the lead character in the TV
show with the killing on AMC she plays
the wife and I thought she's really good
she's one of those those women that that
is their attractive they're beautiful
but they're not like that the type of
like model type of beautiful right um
very real quality yeah real real quality
and there's a strength about her right
that I like that does you know a lot of
times you have a female lead or co-lead
and where they're trying to be like a
man you know that's right Akon me like
male characteristics to be tough you
know i right she doesn't have that she
still has a motherly quality to her but
at the same time still as strong yeah
yeah I think they just broke it down
very simple for that dynamic you know
they mean they make it about family
throughout they kind of remind you of
that seeds that are planted throughout
the movie that just make it very
Universal in the sense of just yeah
you're the family unit there's one actor
that I really liked but he was kind of
barely in it and I thought he was going
to be in it more which was David Morse
he played that the CIA agent that was in
the prison in in South Korea yes boiler
it's in the trailer like I was like you
kind of see him and I'm like oh we're
gonna see him again or their grant tie
back into him
never see me yeah I totally missed him
but Matthew Fox yeah in for the hottest
of seconds yes this guy was in and out
with one line yeah dejak from Los the
bleed character from lost jack I didn't
even know he was in i looked at the IMDb
i was like he was in it and i asked you
and you're like yeah he was the guy in
there yeah I recognize actually his
voice III didn't even see him I don't
know if he just was like hey throw me in
here it was kind of like an Avengers in
iron man when uh what's his face is in
the movie no no Thor in thor where uh
who is it Hawkeye oh yeah yeah yeah
second what i mean but they're planting
that yeah I don't think for this they're
really planned out I think they had shot
a bunch of scenes with him and they cut
him out yeah well they gave him a line
so you get in it but yeah well I know
Damon Lindelof one of the main writers
for lost he he did some writing on this
this script okay which is based on a
book but I heard the book it's a 2006
book by max brooks I heard the book
itself is kind of nothing like this
movie it's just kind of the inspiration
for this movie and it's right it's told
from like many different perspectives
from many different countries okay and
they kind of just like took that as
inspiration to make this movie so they
cut the country's in there yeah I think
their travel all over the place but
apparently I don't know if you saw a
soda Berg's contagion yeah I did like
why is it in these these kind of virus
type movies like this movie was kind of
yeah so why does these viruses always
start like they don't say where it
starts but they always hint it like like
these things starting in Asia so like in
like in contagion it was I forgot where
but it's like in some southeast in
eastern yeah asian country in this one
there like in taiwan somewhere right
where's da the South Korea like always
like are they trying to say something
that like Asian people are like dirty
people who like who cause uh these
viruses to spread I don't know I don't
know I think you that's a really great
question Dennis I think it doesn't
investigating to two big movies
yeah I have that common thread yeah
we're wreaking havoc we're causing all
the problems one of the things that I
thought was a bit weaker than i would
have liked for this type of movie is is
the action just because the director
marc forster he you know he's done
movies like finding neverland and
monsters ball and stranger than fiction
but will the movie that most people know
him from is he directed the james bond
movie quantum of solace which one of the
problems with that movie was the action
was poorly done like they there was like
scenes you could tell from the beginning
in in quantum solace like the car chase
in the very beginning they're just
cutting quickly between like his face
and his shift gear shifting and like
they candidate and I kind of got that in
parts of this movie especially like in
the beginning with there's a sequence in
an apartment building in the dark and
the staircase in the staircase yeah yeah
like I remember asking you I was like
where did that kid come from there's
like a kid in there that's part of the
story I'm like where'd he come from and
and you told me oh yeah he just popped
in him like really cuz I even if you had
to it was like three seconds you know
like you had to catch that frame where
he and Brad Pitt sort of lock eyes for a
moment yeah cuz everything was just kind
of really shaky and dark and you know I
don't mind shaky cam like I think it
works well when it's done well like in a
in a the bourne ultimatum and stuff like
that but in this one I I think
especially in the beginning it was it
was a bit too much and I just couldn't
tell what was going on right yeah
partially I think that was their
intention but you know if you bleed over
into where everything is so gray in
Vegas yeah you don't really you're
having to try and think rather than just
be in the staircase right yeah I did
like how they just jumped right to it
though like they just throw you in the
movie they give you what five minutes of
setup yeah like that and then it's on
like yeah they're in traffic it begins
and I mean that we don't know yet yeah
we did have to wait all right like 20
minutes for you know the action begins
like as soon as that cop gets smashed
and I
that's in the trailer da it is soon as
he gets it that's it like it's on from
that moment well till about five minutes
before it ends and then they kind of
ease you into the credits yeah yeah and
one of the main things that I did say to
you right after we saw the movie is I
almost felt like we didn't see a whole
movie Yeah right I ain't complete to me
just because I'm not going to give any
spoilers but when the movie ends it
doesn't really end they kind of it's not
even a cliffhanger they kind of just end
it in a way that like okay this really
isn't that it even says it you know yeah
just the beginning yeah and so like your
kind of left going okay well I'm waiting
for this other part of the movie that
right it really doesn't happen and
they're kind of saying okay it's gonna
be in the sequel I almost felt like this
was like the premiere episode like a
pilot episode to a TV show like a
two-hour pilot right that next week
we're supposed to tune in right right
more but yeah ok so what what was your
favorite because there are many action
sequences what was your favorite action
sequence I think in in Israel I think in
Israel when they're when they're like in
the when they're running through like
the gate and they're coming up on top of
them yeah yeah yeah we did basically
Israel's is where you see the most
dombey's you see in the trailer there's
thousands and thousands of zombies
coming up and there's a helicopter shoot
him and stuff right I thought that was
pretty cool I like one it was in daytime
so you can actually see what was going
on and it wasn't all shaky and you know
you could see all this stuff happening
you can just see kind of the the
devastation and and disaster type of a
destruction that's happening yeah that I
like the the part with the helicopter
he's cruising up and they're about to
jump on it but it's right over that wall
and then it just it looks like ants you
know they begin to just look like these
swarms of insects because there's just
so many of them yeah so overall I would
give the movie of B minus I think it's
it's it's entertaining but it's not
something you have to rush out and see
if you see it I mean if you want to see
it in the theaters I think it's cool
just to see like all those thousands of
zombies on the big screen which
I think might lose something if you if
you let they run it at home absolutely
um but at the same time the story wise
like it's not like oh you have to run
out and see this what about you I'm
gonna give it a B+ and because i really
like the the score at the very beginning
and at the end it had like kind of a 02
the 80s I'd like the synthesizers okay
so that gets the plus for me I give it
to pile up I like that alright guys so
that's what we thought of World War Z
then post your comments below on the
website or on the YouTube video below as
and as always you can chat with us on
Twitter mine is at Fink hero what's your
twitter it's ad Vince Foster it's that's
it yeah it's nice and easy up and as
always make sure you subscribe to our
channel that's uh and this is the new
think hero channel so you may or may not
be subscribed if you think you already
are it's a think hero pro and you also
can check us out on Facebook that's
facebook.com slash think yo fans
you